in the northern French city of Beauvais
this private laboratory tests for
coronavirus using blood samples for the
equivalent of $30 people without a
prescription can find out within a week
if they are or have been infected the
test measures antibodies that are
created to help the immune system fight
infection it detects if the body is in a
phase of active infection which means
the virus is present and antibodies are
developing if the test is negative the
person is either not infected all there
in the incubation period so it's too
early to see the antibodies the test can
also show if you came into contact with
the virus a few weeks ago because the
body has developed specific antibodies
some health experts say the blood tests
can help track cases but are less
reliable than the nose and throat swab
tests favored by the government and
while private testing is growing in
France it's not enough to fill the
shortfall in the public health system
the French health minister says France
tests 150,000 people a week half the
number in neighboring Germany since the
beginning of the healthcare crisis in
France there haven't been enough testing
kits in the country so it means that
only people in hospitals like this one
or in care homes for the elderly are
being tested for coronavirus President
Emmanuel macron admitted France wasn't
prepared for the crisis but said the
country will be in a position to test
widely in a month when the government
plans to loosen its lockdown rules me
you saw an octopus it did this thing
by May 11th we will be able to test
everyone who shows symptoms we're not
going to test everyone in France that
would make no sense but everyone with
the symptom needs to be able to be
tested that way people with the virus
can be quarantined looked after and
monitored by a doctor this doctor says
that testing is key but so is more
research into understanding the corona
virus among what we're missing is
research on infected people how people
are infected the virus in different
regions and how widely the virus is
circulating in the population these
studies haven't been done the French
government has ordered millions
tests from companies in Europe and Asia
and boosted domestic production but
unless it has the capacity to carry out
widespread testing in May to track an
isolate coronavirus patience easing the
lockdown could put people at risk of a
second wave of infections Natasha Butler
al Jazeera angoulême France